the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology is a
department in the School of Medicine at
OHSU our research programs and
educational programs are synergistic in
that what the researchers look at is
reflected in the education the primary
focus of what we do is on information
and how we can use that information to
improve individual health healthcare
biomedical research and public health
informatics plays a crucial role in our
research the information that is
available about these patients and their
needs is enormous it's way too much
information for people to look through
and so we provide a way to summarize
that and prioritize that information my
research has to do with automated text
processing and automated text mining
what that means is automatically
extracting out knowledge from the
incredible volume of clinical and
publication tax that we have my
co-investigators and I use neural
imaging techniques to map functional
networks in the brain and specifically
we use techniques such as functional
magnetic resonance imaging and optical
micro angiography to measure changes in
blood flow and blood volume in the brain
this is very information-rich and we
have to use a lot of computational
approaches and integrate those
approaches ultimately with clinical
information to address the scientific
question apparent because the different
faculty use many different methods in
their research it really creates a
diverse array of techniques and research
subjects that benefit each other's
research and also our students
Oh Hsu is by its nature very
interdisciplinary we have such a broad
array of faculty and so many
opportunities to collaborate that people
of very different backgrounds can find a
home here it's not only being in
beautiful downtown Portland but it's
also the fact that our program is so
well balanced so that we're we're very
broad we cover most areas of informatics
we wind up with quite a range of people
at different stages of their informatics
career adventure that I think is a
really nice mix people choose OHSU over
other informatics educational
institutions because of the experience
of the faculty and because of the
opportunities here for learning
exploring and for projects we've got
students coming in at all levels
graduate students postdoctoral fellows
physicians who have completed residency
training and they come from both
mathematical sciences computational
sciences and the biological sciences I
actually got my education at OHSU the
education at OHSU is broadly based and
allows students to select their own
interests it's also one of the 17
national library medicine fellowship
programs and so when people come to OHSU
either on campus or through distance
learning they know that they're getting
their education from an institution that
is experienced in teaching informatics
professionals the distance learning
program has been really important to us
it's enabled individuals who want to
pursue careers and informatics to do so
without leaving their jobs or their
geographic location and so forth we
communicate with them by email we see
them at scientific meetings
conferences sometimes they combine visit
us so we get to know them well I've had
a great opportunity to mentor students
both in the distance learning program
and here on campus it's been wonderful
to see the opportunities that they've
taken and how they've launched their
careers usually starting from work that
they did here in the program we've
really done a fantastic job of reaching
lots of different learners and I think
that the department has a great
opportunity to really be at the center
both at the institution and really
nationally of providing pragmatic
solutions to the issues that plague not
only informatics itself but also the
broader healthcare system we have the
opportunity to use these tools to
improve the care of patients to make
that care and that experience better and
to make it more economical so this is a
really exciting time to be working in
the field of clinical informatics
because of the large volume and the
innovation in the research that we do we
push the field forward we look at new
ways to use information technology new
algorithms to apply to the data and so
forth and that benefits the field as a
whole